before video begins the most epic collab
of all time has happened pewdiepie
terraria look at this [ __ ] hey
look at this oh wait you can't see the
back
look at this [ __ ] we also have exclusive
pewdiepie terraria figurine only 20
macaronis
no legs gang we also have the no legs
shirt
i think i'm wearing it right now yeah i
am no legs gang check it out link in the
description
i'm really it's really cool to work with
such a cool game i'm super proud
it's awesome huge peepee all right roll
the intro let's do this video
leave your memes on the reddit
[Music]
i missed last week's lawyer for no
reason whatever
what was the last video you liked a
music video called coco but you deleted
it here's the still image of that video
still images are still allowed amazing
i i don't think i'm allowed to show any
actual footage of the video
which is fully understandable because it
was just the most horrific video i
ever made and i apologize to all the
melons out there that happened to see it
just reminding that this clip exists i
remember this
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
oh man we went bowling
and ken just went for it i can't believe
it can me and the boys get only white
to surprise our kids back home i can't
tell if this is a meme or not what the
[ __ ]
that's 46 thousand uploads is this legit
like i can't imagine this group of
people going hey boys
pewdiepie just uploaded the latest
episode of minecraft let's
watch it oh it is legit i didn't know an
army guys can like minecraft and karma
i'm sorry
this is enough proof that i'm in the
military i apologize
what if we use zero percent of the brain
oh god what is this how much
is a ten dollar uber oh my god
i meant how much how many miles how much
miles that's how you speak right
yeah download small very tiny minuscule
pp god dang it
pewdiepie comment said but he deleted it
an hour ago i feel betrayed
is that like a personal attack or
something uh
wait what i did delete [ __ ] what is he
talking about wait everyone
everyone thinks i deleted it wait so mr
beast made a short
video where he said pewdiepie i want you
to leave a comment on the video and if
you're not pewdiepie scroll down and see
if he did because if he did
i'm gonna pin it until he comments me
and the boys aren't moving we're staying
here
comment cutie pies please uncomfortable
your feet stink
it's right there it's right there
it's right there what do you mean i
deleted it if i commented but he deleted
what are you saying it's right there
loki can we get this the most like
comment sorry seth everman
he's looking unimpressed in the corner
i gave the shades the pewdiepie just for
the video but he kept them
so i can't ask for it back it doesn't
feel good but
what i asked if i could keep them and
you said yes you can't
retract the gift simon huh
what the [ __ ] i didn't just take them
[Music]
hey i can send you some i'll try and get
what are they
uh i can hit i can set you up with some
ultra great british flag sunglasses
assignment
just uh dm in your address and i i got
you fam
got this go go that mp4 that's good [ __ ]
oh man this is the gucci forbidden song
it's up on spotify by the way if you
guys want to listen to it like
just can't see the music video who will
win a ripped swedish god
i don't call me that or one fat american
boy
well he's got that weight advantage i'll
give him that [ __ ]
six nine pewdiepie having their music
video removed by youtube also pewdiepie
wait they removed six nines video
what no it's back up it's back up gamers
huh i guess his his could get
back up that's fine
does he bite no but he can hurt you in
other ways youtube doesn't give a [ __ ]
but creators they don't care about
creator
i saw you being born and i saw you die
[Laughter]
rest in peace coco rest in peace
i'm so sorry coco he was like a father
to me
oh [ __ ] she commented hila i made it
into a pewdiepie video ultimate
achievement all like
sorry you had to go through that eli i'm
sorry [ __ ] hell
that looked awful hey what a cool fan
art thank you so much
it lives on the spirit still lives on
they can take our cocoa video
but they can't take our freedom what was
the last video you liked oh
pewdiepie coco and then you guys deleted
it and kept the new
joke santa thank you santa
shout out to santa everyone got my
cancers tomorrow moon today we'll
likely be bringing licensure my hope is
that one by the time i am back
up coco will have returned to some
extent oh
man yeah i wish you a speedy recovery my
brother but that ain't happening
yo whoa holy sh
hey no
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
amazing swindly legend
well i meant it when i said like yeah
we're done with a coco meme but
if someone's worked on something for six
months like yeah yeah that was amazing
huge pp shout out uh orange this is an
orange pear
this a pear disappear
i got the joke i understand the joke now
[Laughter]
still
[Music]
is this pewdiepie reference intentional
oh
i've seen this channel they threw like
bowling balls on trampoline and [ __ ]
big peepee regardless if it referenced
or not never trust a man with a mustache
liar [ __ ] well that's a beer that's not
a mustache
get it right kids you're nine years old
i am
my apologies it's not easy out there
being
a child yo oh they used to terra cotta
that looks sick
huge pp oh big ups man
oh let's see how how does one build this
oh [ __ ] hey damn that's sick
marion oh the [ __ ] helmet dude
oh hell yeah that's so cool
thanks guys pewds and marzia loving maya
meanwhile edgar
[Music]
oh eddie song if you are pewdiepie click
here
pewdiepie comment on this video 2.5
million people
made with a remi matic maybe i am
pewdiepie
made with mimatic wow thanks me matic
for making that that's so cool
mr beast just surprised pewdiepie and
youtube search popularity for the first
time
we aren't kidding diss track on mr beats
coming right up
it's a joke congratulations mr b
oh god mr beast would have to make a
campaign against himself
like he did with t-series
his story system in minecraft a bunch of
19 year old fearless
[ __ ] yeah uh just wait until you see
what else i've been doing it's insane
then
guy at planet fitness brings a large
water bottle employee
wouldn't that make you a goddamn
criminal his water bottle too large
he could kill someone
also actually they're sold out never
mind
sorry i told you guys to buy them fast
and you did heavy bubbles
we have two kilos five kilos and 10
kilos
that's too big that should be illegal
what if i can carry it if you can't
carry
you can't drink you die you can even
become stronger
just by getting it back home
what a great commercial hot and stuff
don't buy other stuff
don't just don't that's great
so how heavy is the 10 kilo one
found pewdiepie's first ever subscriber
on youtube
imac g it's weird how i remember this
i swear i've seen this before wow
strange how cameras on mars are better
quality than pipa it's my camera quality
still that bad you can see my [ __ ]
pimples
i'm 31 years old [ __ ] days
i need worse camera quality bro center
get him come on six nine come on [ __ ]
find me spotify
check it out link in the description
yeah
hey [ __ ]
that's weird i look like my dad dude
[Music]
what the hell hey kids i'll get right in
right to it would you like to see your
shaker cup in zero g i'm an undergrad
doing zero g research and i got one more
flight before i graduate
this would happen first week of may
photo up
second week say the word and it will
happen absolutely
the g fuel cup sold out so quickly
people are taking desperate measures to
get one
and i respect it yeah yeah ask g
fuel to connect with you guys that
sounds funny phyllis and ken whoever
talks the loudest becomes the leader
also felix and ken
drive winter time
i think i won that argument all right i
think that's it i
refuse to watch this ah
hell yeah oh wow
wow thank you don't ever want to see
that again
oh arigato go silence
it's better and worse at the same time i
can't oh god i can't i'm sorry
burrito just need to stop i heard he has
his own
automated storage system dude
ladies please i'm married okay
yes you can see my storage system but
that's it
then you have to leave oh no
no i actually did find it in the chest
don't worry gamers there's my automated
system
my registered automated minecraft system
is storage system is perfect
okay don't worry about it it still works
i got it i got it
uh we have an expert here teach us how
to use it properly okay let's see this
let's see those pools boy
[Laughter]
okay what is happening
oh he's changing stage oh
he's more powerful than anyone ever know
student my dad is high teacher
tall not high the dead thank you for
that still image to me i really
appreciate it guys
oh yeah i've been kissed by a guy i felt
that beard that i don't want to feel
and i'll never forget it ken's 10th
youtube anniversary is
oh god small peepee moving on
[Laughter]
i can't can believe i just laughed at a
[ __ ] avengers meme in 2021 but that's
good
that's good [ __ ] i heard he still likes
the original diss track
tab open oh my god
and he has an automatic minecraft
storage system
oh [ __ ] yeah that's the wood i mentioned
hell yeah
we got the dragon left gamers i'm gonna
do it all right
the grand finale your meme gets 30k
upvotes no
why this meme [ __ ] i guess i should go
back
i i just didn't want to create a whole
bunch of drama and [ __ ]
i [ __ ] amazing fan art from matrix
as always insane holy [ __ ]
pug owners my little cutie the pug yeah
100 accurate absolutely feel like
subscribe youtube has crushed a bit of
your enthusiasm we all really appreciate
your content and we'll always support it
oh
thanks guys that's all right i
i was a bit pissed off not gonna lie for
a couple days but
i'm over it i think i know where this is
going
[Laughter]
oh poor six nine
all right i really really want to thank
you guys for all the support
especially during times like these maine
i appreciate you
thank you thank you for all the subs uh
i'm sorry to everyone that worked hard
on the video that's why i feel worse so
bad
it was just supposed to be a fun thing
for the fans but uh hopefully the ones
that saw it got to see it at least
it's out on spotify if you want to check
it out but that's it for me for now
see you gamers